my relationship with the Internet
reminds me of the setup to a tea shade
horror movie you know the blissfully
happy family moves into their perfect
new home excited about their perfect
future and it's sunny outside and the
birds are chirping and then it gets dark
and there are noises from an attic and
we realize that that perfect new house
isn't so perfect when I started working
at Google in 2006 Facebook was just a
two-year-old and Twitter hadn't yet been
born and I was in absolute awe of the
Internet and all of its promise to make
us closer and smarter and more free but
as we were doing the inspiring worth of
building search engines and video
sharing sites and social networks
criminals dictators and terrorists were
figuring out how to use those same
platforms against us and we didn't have
the foresight to stop them over the last
few years geopolitical forces have come
online to wreak havoc and in response
Google supported a few car easy me to
set up a new group called jigsaw with
the mandate to make people safer front
frets like by the extremism censorship
persecution threats that feel very
personal to me because I was born in
Iran and I left in the aftermath of a
violent revolution but had come to
realize that even if we had all of the
resources of all of the technology
companies in the world we'd still fail
if we overlooked one critical ingredient
the human experiences of the victims and
perpetrators of those threats there are
many challenges I could talk to you
about today I'm gonna focus on just two
the first is
terrorism so in order to understand the
radicalization process we met with
dozens of former members of violent
extremist groups one was a British
schoolgirl who'd been taken off of a
plane at London Heathrow as she was
trying to make her way to Syria to join
Isis and she was 13 years old so I sat
down with her and her father and I said
why and she said I was looking at
pictures of what life is like in Syria
and I thought I was gonna go and live in
the Islamic Disney World that's what she
saw an Isis she thought she'd meet and
marry a jihadi Brad Pitt that goes
shopping in the mall all day and have
happily ever after Isis understands what
drives people and they carefully craft a
message for each audience just look at
how many languages they translate their
marketing material into they make
pamphlets radio shows and videos in not
just English in Arabic but German
Russian French Turkish Kurdish Hebrew
Mandarin Chinese I've even seen an Isis
produce video in sign language just
think about that for a second Isis took
the time and made the effort to ensure
their message is reaching the deaf and
hard of hearing it's actually not tech
savviness that is the reason why Isis
wins hearts and minds
it's that insight into the prejudices
the vulnerabilities the desires of the
people they're trying to reach that does
that that's why it's not enough for the
online platforms to focus on removing
recruiting material if we want to have a
shorter building meaningful technology
that's going to counter radicalization
we have to start with the human journey
at its core so we went to Iraq to speak
to young men who bought into the Isis's
promise of heroism and
righteousness who taken up arms to fight
for them and then who defected after
they witness the brutality of Isis's
rule and I'm sitting there in this
makeshift prison in the north of Iraq
with this 23 year old who'd actually
trained as a suicide bomber before
defecting and he says I have I've Dinh
Syria full of hope and immediately I had
two of my comprised possessions
confiscated my passport and my mobile
phone
so the symbols of his physical and
digital Liberty were taken away from him
on arrival and then this is the way that
he described that moment of loss to me
he said you know in Tom and Jerry
when Jerry wants to escape and then Tom
locks the door and swallows the key you
see it bulging out of his throat as it
travels down and of course I really
could see the image that he was
describing and I really did connect with
the feeling that he was trying to convey
which was one of doom when you know
there's no way out and I was wondering
like what if anything could have changed
his mind the day that he left home so I
asked if you knew everything that you
know now about the suffering in the
corruption brutality that day you left
him would you still have gone and he
said yes I thought holy crap he said yes
and then he said at that point I was so
brainwashed I wasn't taking in any big
contradictory information I couldn't
have been swayed well what if you knew
everything that you know now six months
before the day that you left at that
point I think it probably would have
changed my mind
radicalization isn't this yes or no
choice it's the process during which
people have questions about ideology
religion the living conditions and
they're coming online for answers which
is an opportunity to reach them and
there are videos online from people who
have answers defectors for example
telling the story of their journey into
and out of violence stories like the
one from that man I met in the Iraqi
prison there are locals who uploaded
cell phone footage of what life is
really like in the Caliphate under
Isis's rule there are clerics who are
sharing peaceful interpretations of
Islam but you know what these people
generally don't have the marketing
prowess of Isis they risk their lives to
speak up and confront terrorist
propaganda and then they tragically
don't reach the people who most need to
hear from them and we wanted to see if
technology could change that so in 2016
we partnered with moonshot CVE to pilot
a new approach to countering
radicalization called the redirect
method it uses the power of online
advertising to bridge the gap between
those susceptible to Isis's messaging
and those credible voices that are
debunking that messaging and it works
like this someone looking for extremist
material say they search for how do I
join Isis we'll see an ad appear that
invites them to watch a YouTube video of
a cleric of a defector some someone who
has an authentic answer and that
targeting is based not on a profile of
who they are but of determining
something that's directly relevant to
their query or question during this
there are eight-week pilot in English in
Arabic we reached over 300,000 people
who had expressed an interest in or
sympathy towards of jihadi group these
people were now watching videos that
could prevent them from making
devastating choices and because violent
extremism isn't confined to any one
language religion or ideology the
redirect method is now being deployed
globally to protect people being courted
online by violent ideologues whether
they're Islamists white supremacist or
other violent extremists with the goal
of giving them the chance to hear from
someone on the other side of that
journey give them the chance to choose a
different path it turns out that often
the bad guys are good at exploiting the
internet not because theirs
kind of technological geniuses but
because they understand what makes
people tick I want to give you a second
example online harassment online
harasses also work to figure out what
will resonate with another human being
but not to recruit them like Isis does
but to cause them pain imagine this
you're a woman you're married you have a
kid you post something on social media
and in a reply you're told that you'll
be raped that your son will be watching
details of when and where in fact your
home address is put online for everyone
to see that feels like a pretty real
threat do you think you'd go home do you
think you'd continue doing the thing
that you're doing would you continue
doing that thing that's irritating your
attacker online abuse has become this
perverse art figuring out what makes
people angry what makes people afraid
what makes people insecure and then
pushing those pressure points until
they're silenced when online harassment
goes unchecked free speech is stifled
and even the people hosting the
conversation throw up their arms and
call it quits closing their comment
sections and their forums altogether
that means we're actually losing spaces
online to meet and exchange ideas and
we're online spaces remain we descend
into echo chambers with people who think
just like us but that enables the spread
of disinformation that facilitates
polarization what if technology instead
could enable empathy at scale this was
the question that motivated our
partnership with Google's counter abuse
team Wikipedia and newspapers like the
New York Times we wanted to see if we
could build machine learning models that
could understand the emotional impact of
language could we predict which comments
were likely to make someone else leave
the online conversation
and that's no mean feat like there's no
trivial accomplishment for for AI to be
able to do something like that I mean
just consider these two examples of
messages that could have been sent to me
last week
break a leg at Ted and I'll break your
legs at Ted you're a human that's why
that's obvious of difference to you even
though the words are pretty much the
same but for AI it takes some training
to teach the models to recognize that
difference the beauty of building AI
that can tell the difference is that AI
can then scale to the size of the online
toxicity phenomenon and that was our
goal in building our technology called
perspective with the help of perspective
the New York Times for example has
increased spaces online for conversation
before our collaboration they only had
comments enabled on just 10% of their
articles with the help of machine
learning they have that number up to 30%
so they've tripled it and we're still
just getting started but this is about
way more than just making moderators
more efficient right now I can see you
and I can gauge how what I'm saying is
landing with you
you don't have that opportunity online
imagine if machine learning could give
commenters as their typing real-time
feedback about how their words might
land just like facial expressions do in
a face-to-face conversation machine
learning isn't perfect and still makes
plenty of mistakes but if we can build
technology that understands the
emotional impact of language you can
build empathy that means that we can
have dialogue between people with
different politics different worldviews
different values and we can reinvigorate
the spaces online that most of us have
given up on when people use technology
to exploit and harm others they're
preying on our human fears and
vulnerabilities if we ever thought that
we could build an Internet insulated
from the dark side of humanity we were
wrong
if we want today to build technology
that can overcome the challenges that we
face we have to throw our entire selves
into understanding the issues and into
building solutions that are as human as
the problems they aim to solve let's
make that happen
thank you
[Applause]